all right Gail thank you very much there
are questions about the pace of
reopening in Europe as well as here in
the United States several European
countries are also letting stores reopen
and giving people more freedom to go out
Italy reported its lowest daily death
toll since just after the lockdown began
and some familiar signs of life are
returning Chris Livesay is there and
they're off joggers allowed once again
to run in parks long off limits for two
months virtually all Italians have had
to stay at home but today life begins
returning to something nearing normal in
Rome's iconic company Fiore flower
market the florists have returned estado
defeat it's been hard economically and
personally he says I'm part of this
Piazza cafes like the antique Oh cafe
Greco the oldest in Rome can once again
serve coffee in two hundred and sixty
years has this cafe ever been closed
never never closed about not even during
World War two get out see I get out see
him so for now it's only take away and
it's only in disposable cups not exactly
an Italian tradition Italy is still in
the full throes of the pandemic says
Prime Minister Jews epic home day
stressing that the loosening of
restrictions must not be seen as a
signal that we're all free schools
churches and museums remain shut
elsewhere in Europe masks are mandatory
in Spain where rules against outdoor
exercise were also lifted
in Germany widely praised for containing
the outbreak churches resumed service
and this morning workers returned to
automaker Ford's European headquarters
but things aren't getting better
everywhere the outbreak is worsening in
Russia which recorded its worst day in
new cases Sunday with more than 10,000
but there's cause for celebration here
in Italy where outdoor markets like this
one are finally starting to reopen now
most stores are going to remain closed
for at least two more weeks
hairdressers has been closed this entire
time as I'm sure you can tell and
they're gonna stay that way at least
until next month
Anthony Chris lives say with some
encouraging signs in Rome thank you
Chris